and I like the way people are finding
different things to do in lockdown you
know home fitness and meditation you've
gone the booze route maybe so you post
your mixology everyday or just when the
mood takes you know just when the just
I'm not too drunk to work my phone is
when I do it no when i we just sort of
doing it periodically every every every
week or so something like that what
people are loving them we've got some
tweets here who knew stanley tucci
making a Negroni was mike ink somebody
else I want Stanley Tucci to manhandle
me the way he slams down his cocktail
ingredients and no and that was my agent
even Chris Evans Chris Evans posted this
I loved Stanley Tucci on some most days
after we finished filming on the first
Captain America movie Stanley would make
us martinis in his trailer would you do
that every day
the the Marty yeah yeah yeah I always
have I like to bring up a portable
cocktail set that I bring to set and at
the end of the day if it's the
appropriate time we make martinis for
whoever would like to join me that is
such a lovely thing well that's nice you
know it's civilized very civilized
[Music]